uh Mickey let's start with you first
Reese Witherspoon and Casey Musgraves
are producers on this new show what was
that call like for you finding out that
they wanted you to be a part of this it
was an absolute hell yes I was so
excited I'm you know Casey Musgrave and
I are our label mates I go way back with
her and I've just gone way back with
Reese Witherspoon in my mind because
I've been such a fan of this for so long
and you know when Reese Witherspoon
calls you answer so yeah I was really
really excited
That's so exciting uh Orville for you
you know obviously you know you're going
to be part of the show you know that
they're producers on this what was it
like having them on set what was it like
seeing them in action uh recent Casey
yeah yeah it was amazing I mean you know
I think this entire concept was born out
of this conversation that they had where
they were you know sort of talking about
how country can sometimes feel like it
has closed doors to certain you know
people or perspectives and so it was
lovely to see something they
we're talking about come to fruition and
for us to be a part of it it was a
really inspiring set it was always it
always felt really
uh yeah passionate and loving it didn't
feel like we were making a TV show per
se which felt really collaborative and
beautiful and set all the time
that's actually such a nice feeling
because I'm sure you know it's not
always like that there's a lot it was a
lot for sure but
um well listen Casey Musgraves is so
fantastic uh Reese Witherspoon we know
she's got the pipes we've heard her and
walked the line we've heard her and sing
would any of you want to do a
collaboration with Reese on a song yeah
yeah absolutely do a song with with
Reese Witherspoon and a heartbeat
challenging thing about being a part of
this show how how hard is it judging
other people letting them go that was
just
you get so invested in them you know you
want them all to do so well and you're
like
I'm like freaking Hercules like I'm like
Hercules
contestants and so it's like when you
have to tell them no like we've all been
on that end before we've all been told
no at some point and it never feels good
and didn't have to be the person to tell
them you notice I made y'all say no the
most yes we do know
it was heartbreaking and it's also it
was put on us it's hard because we we
wanted this show not to feel sort of
like typical uh music competition shows
where we're kind of maybe judging it off
of you know technicalities or whatever
it everyone was so talented and so
unique as artists it sometimes just felt
impossible to even make a decision
because you feel like well everyone here
is so special and so we drank a lot yeah
we we drank a lot of whiskey
to try and get the courage I mean it was
it was it's really heartbreaking
we drank a lot of with me and they took
them with me from us yeah I remember at
this
we just had to stop drinking whiskey
because then we would be like crying
yeah
all the time they didn't take my whiskey
because I'm like this if I just act
chilled the whole time
here then your eyes get along slipping
in your seat it was like a drawing straw
situation eventually yeah we were just
like who was who's gonna tell them yeah
that was definitely you know some of the
hardest you know things to have to watch
them do but he didn't lose any sleep
over him no I did absolutely not you
know but the reason why I didn't lose
sleep is because I told all the
contestants when I first had them by
myself I said listen at the end of the
day you all need to understand we're
making a TV show we're looking for a
winner everybody's going home even a
winner so whether you go home now or
later just take everything you learned
and apply to your life when this show's
over to get your career because your
career don't start now your career
starts when the show's over see I'm
saying because right now you're in this
limbo on the show you can't do nothing
you're in a bubble this is where you're
at in a bubble so take everything you
learn and then go out and be great
that's why I was able to sleep good at
night because I knew every day I was
going to come and try to give advice
that I was you know taught from other
artists
um and try to help you know give them as
many tools as they can so yeah and I
didn't have it tells me people goodbye
exactly right meanwhile Mick and I are
like crying
makeup chair forgot what crazy outfit I
was gonna wear oh my God that's crazy
I played dress up I took a picture it
was awesome I played dresses people
think I dress crazy just wait
obviously obviously you guys get along
so well but did you ever have moments
where you would fight over an artist
someone's like yes keep and someone else
was like no yes and that's what I loved
because I feel like everybody always
agree somebody's lying yeah you know I
mean and I like a little drama from time
to time I'm not a little confrontation
but I but here's the thing I love that
we didn't agree 100 do you mind how
boring I would be if we all yep I like
them don't like them no but you know
like we said this but sometimes it was
clear yes it was very clear there was a
couple though that we all oh yeah well
because the atmosphere on set was just
authentic that was kind of the name of
the game for the entire series you know
and so that was the same for us like I
never felt
produced or coerced or scripted I mean
we got to just have our opinions as
artists ourselves and it felt very
sincere the entire process yeah
because I love passion I love how each
you know Mickey was passionate about the
artist that she wanted to see go through
or not I love how orva was and I was the
same way you know we all had people that
we were passionate and it was good to
see that because that's real yeah
true well congratulations so nice
talking to you I can just feel the
chemistry it's great thanks guys the
whole time thank you